through the city like I'm get it the
city like if
youin and now
Brandon six
boy
sh what is up fam it is Monday morning
9:01 a.m. exactly Pacific Time welcome
this is the same old show we've been
doing I know you guys like what's
happening right now this is completely
different oh my God what happened to the
channel we just updated the set my boy
Brian Johnson update the set he builds
all the sets here at thick boy firing
the kid he did King of the stain golden
hour he did Brian super boring set he's
done all of them fight companion set and
uh chin wanted a little refresher of
this set and so what chin wants we do
what chin ask we do so this is the new
set some uh it's a Cool vibe yeah onos a
little different it's a little you guys
have more room now right I feel like you
guys have more room what's funny is like
we have a little bit less room it's kind
of trippy yeah really it looks like more
open but yeah hope you guys dig it same
show new set we'll adjust it a little
bit too we'll see we'll see tweaks here
and there uh what's going on
kids uh I haven't seen you guys in a hot
second as far as the shop show is
concerned I've done golden hours I've
done fire the kid since then but uh it's
been uh shoot 3 weeks four weeks but
it's a good time to take off because the
UFC goes into hibernation as well so the
UFC season is ramping back up you have a
fight night this freaking Saturday anive
and Walker Johnny Walker 2 um I assume
the winner of that gets the next shot at
the title um there's a have you guys
been seeing the rumbles going on about
anive and uh
Alex Pier have you seen any of
this yeah I don't know what's going on
there because I thought to myself well
don't that's if he gets by Johnny Walker
now Johnny Walker Alex Pier is a fun
fight that one we can sell and C's in a
tough spot because you know he's had
those draws you know he had the weird
draw with uh our
boy and then he
just so he had the draw with Yan right
and then he
bunch of decisions and then he had the
illegal knee with Johnny
Walker it it it hasn't been a great uh
end of the year for him December October
will shoot then he took a basically an
entire year off after the draw the split
draw against Jan then took entire year
off and then illegally uh need Johnny
Walker so he's in a tough spot and he's
fighting this Saturday you assume with a
win he gets the
nod
bad for business but as a purist it's
what you got to do he's it'd be tough if
he's your champ just is what it is
nothing against them for the UFC they're
like but Johnny Walker Alex Pi that's a
fun fight come on Johnny Johnny can win
that fight tough one for him though
Johnny can do it Johnny can do it but uh
yeah back to the whole point of this
there's been uh you know it's been the
off season for the UFC so they're
ramping back up and then it gets popping
because then uh January 20th you get the
big UFC pay-per-view with in uh Canada
was at Toronto you got our boy
Strickland vers dupes which that fight
is damn near impossible to call I I'm
sure I'll do some
more investigating into it as we get
close to that fight but that fight is
damn near impossible to call it's a plus
110 minus 130 the odd show the same
thing Rael penon uh Bueno Silva all
right uh Neil
Magny Arnold Allen
most all right the card is terrible
that's all right that main event is uh
popping man that card is tough for a
pay-per-view but that main event uh kick
kicks off kind of the season for the UFC
the pay-per-view season and we are doing
a fight campaign in Austin Texas with Mr
Joseph Rogan Eddie Bravo Brian K of
course is on tour like he is every
single weekend which is annoying but he
has to do what he has to do uh so they
sent out the the bat signal and Joey
Diaz answered so you got Joseph Rogan
Joseph
Diaz and Eddie Bravo and myself for
fight campaign so it's gonna be a fun
one man that main event is tasty the
rest of
it would be a bad fight night but you're
getting paid just for that main event
pay-per-view um and then after that
they're they're rolling I'm still so
curious what the heck the UFC has up
their sleeve for UFC 300 now there's two
train of thought here so UFC 100 I mean
Banger Banger UFC 200 good God you know
you had the Fallout of Jon Jones so they
inserted anon silv on short notice
against DC either way that whole card
was stacked prelim stacked you know FX
card stacked then you to pay-per-view
stacked that's where UFC 100 and 200 so
300 you know there's a level of
expectations that UFC knows the fan base
is
requiring and it hasn't met that yet I'm
sure we're going to get some
announcements Mr uh Dana White has been
on vacation he did announce two fights I
think yesterday or the day before on his
social
media um great fights which we'll get
into so he announced two big fights um
but nothing
about the marquee fight for 300 they
don't have a main event yet they don't
have a main event and not only we
expecting a main event but we're
expecting even more so usually you know
you've had multiple title fights on 100
200 you have big big fights announced
and when you look at the lay of the land
who's available I don't know what
they're GNA do and I also you can go
down one lane where maybe the UFC
doesn't care there's that they're set
what are you going to do yeah 300's not
popping like 100 200 and there's a level
of expectation that we're all used to
the UFC's like times are different man
we're good we don't do that stuff
anymore
it could be that could be that God look
at that look at this freaking C this is
UFC 100 ready for this Brock Lesnar
Frank mayor one of my favorite fights of
all time uh GSP Thiago Alves Dan
Henderson Michael
bisbing um that's where Dan hton got his
logo from and then Michael bisbing went
on to do crazy uh legendary stuff after
that fight John fit Paulo Thiago akiyama
Alan Belcher on the pre lims you had
markk Coleman Stephen boner J Jones ever
heard of him Jake O'Brien he just beat
the crap out of Jake O'Brien Jim Miller
M
danzing Hung Kim TJ Grant Tommy Lawler
CB
doway I mean just stacked and go to UFC
200 chin so the so the thing is with the
UFC it's like the the fans especially
the hardcores our expectations are so
big for 300 I the picture I'm P I'm
thinking
you know the the 300 poster the from the
movie the Spartan poster like they could
do so much fun stuff around it but the
UFC might be like I don't care anymore
we're good you're going to buy it no
matter what you can buy it whether it's
at the Apex T-Mobile three you know
three main events on there uh three
title fights on them he guys even buy no
matter what they're just at a different
level they're not on the come up anymore
they've made it at the top of the hill
they don't have to do anything kind of a
bummer but also
I get it so the this is UFC 200 now I'll
just think of the fights we have
announced so far which the fights
announced so far are good but there's no
big- time Main Event so you had Amanda
Nunes Misha Tate Brock Lesnar Mark hunt
DC anerson Silva That was supposed to be
Jon Jones so you have three um big boy
fights on there then you had Jose Aldo
uh Frankie Edgar Cain Velasquez Travis
Brown opened up your main
card on the card you had Pena Kat
zingano Kelvin gastam Johnny Hendricks
TJ Dillashaw aansa Sage
northcut undercard you had Joe Lo loan
Diego Sanchez Gard musasi Jim Miller
gy your worst fight on that card was a
young raging Sage North cut outside that
it is Hall of Famers all across the
board whether it was the the prelims on
Fox prelims on UFC Fight Pass Hall of
Famers on every single
card so for UFC 300 there you know the
UFC set these expectations and maybe
they didn't plan out far enough because
they've been going with all the you know
dealing with all this stuff maybe it's
the the lawsuit going on with them um
who knows who knows but right now you
have confirmed Charles Olivera uh Armen
cukan yep Arman cukan that's a great
fight
great
fight not a main event for for 300 not a
main event for a regular pay-per-view
not a main event but for 300 that that's
that's on your main card you could put
start with
that Bo nickel Cody brundridge
I uh if I'm going base off 100 200
that's on the
prelims Calvin Kar Al Germaine Sterling
that's the main card but again it's not
a it's not a seller Yi and Racket great
fight probably on the prelims if this is
200 so they got some work to do and the
UFC never disappoints um usually they
never disappoint so the question is what
do they have up their sleeve that's
going to blow the fan base's hair back
for UFC
300 well Connor's not fighting that was
a big cash C we all thought thought
Conor was going to hit 300 nope he's at
International fight week so I think and
this to me shows the UFC's a little bit
like we don't have to go too crazy on
300 the fan base is there let's not
waste Conor on that that card just for
being 300 is going to sell well Conor
can sell well no matter what we do so
we're put him on a different fight card
so Connor's out Connor Chandler's out we
all thought that was G be 300 that's out
who else you got Brock Lesnar is not
happening Ron is not happening Nate Diaz
isn't happening I know that for a
fact
so there's no like old heads that they
can bring out you know what I'm saying
like like Legend old
heads I honly thought they were going to
do Alex pier and uh Aspen at heavyweight
yeah that that was teased a little bit
wouldn't that knock your dick in the
dirt that's something you be like that's
300 quality that that gets me excited
there's nothing like oh my God this is
not there I should say this the fights
they've out I'm take my money but as far
as like the getting the cow like your
dad going dang how about the 300 card
there's nothing like that which that's
what we're
expecting card's great but again to get
the casuals on board to get in the
mainstream it's just not there
yet they uh
Islam got remember Ramadan too take that
away I bet they announced Leon Edwards
and a b
Mohammad great fight if you're hardcore
that means take my money casuals are
[Music]
like so I wonder if the UFC is just
waiting to see what happens with Sean
Strickland dupes because the winner of
that depending how that fight goes could
fight at 300 do you bring Izzy back do
you do a super fight with
that
if they're really trying to make some
waves do they and this is so messed up
to do I do not agree with this do they
skip over Bel muhamad and put shott in
Leon Edwards that'll make some
waves Leon Edwards
shovot does the winner of Strickland D
polies fight Hamot at
300 even though did was that was that
Health scare thing what's going on with
that yeah I he post that weird video but
is it old they had him take it down he
deleted himself so it could have been
when he first got sick with the co
remember that that time yeah he was
horribly sick but it could be the
infection when he had his his hand
injury so I don't
know yeah there's nothing they can
really
do because Ramadan ties up a ton of
their talented
guys
depending how the strictland D polies
fight go you could possibly even though
Izzy said he's taking a long time off he
could bring Izzy back I think espe if
dy's wins because the sto The Narrative
theirs great I think Izzy's their best
option in terms of star like quality I
that's the only guy cuz Conor like you
said is out out Sugar's fighting cheetah
later like they need somebody to hang
their hat on with that card I think it's
Izzy Izzy's by far the biggest name out
there kind of chilling
but he also said he wants a long
break John J Jones offly
out hey here's a wild idea why not do
aspen ol ver
Stipe
yeah winner fights Jon Jones because
nobody's calling and this is not a knock
on Steve I absolutely love him nobody I
know besid Steve B's family is calling
for him versus John Jones everyone's
lukewarm on this like all right I guess
it's like this weird legendary fight Tom
ask put in work he's the number one guy
in the world a lot of people favor him
over Jon Jones so you're just going to
have him wait for how long what what can
you do with Aspen you have wait till
Jon's peack is 100% better and then he
has to fight Stipe and then aspadol
fights that's stupid that's
insane so you have a healthy
Stipe you have the number one guy Aspen
all Jon's out of the picture with a torn
pack they're both both chilling St Bay
was ready to fight as when I was ready
to
fight st's a big name as when I was
getting
bigger if you really want to get the UK
fan base you do Leon Edwards B Bal
muhamad Aspen
Stipe get that UK fan base tuning in the
only thing is how healthy is Stipe I
recently saw him walking out somewhere
and he was kind of limping did you guys
see that you got that fighter swag walk
yeah I mean I just don't know how
like but he he's ready to fight he's
healthy enough to fight Jon Jones but is
he going I'm only fighting one more you
guys see how I get out of bed I'm only
fighting one more just to get that bank
but UFC 300's a big
boy but he probably agreed to certain
okay yeah there you go okay he walks
like Sylvester
store he does look like an older
dude
yesh yeah I saw that I'm like I don't
know 100% I don't know if we could
qualify him as 100% but that might be
stipe's current landscape that he that's
his hundo that's his
hundo I just
don't and 300s going to be a big card
especially with the mark and the stack
fights they put on nothing major right
now
but it just made that's the only fight
that makes complete sense where you like
hold up UFC 300 you have the heavyweight
interterm title shot on the line as
Aspen's coming off that huge win he took
on two weeks notice back up the bags pay
both those boys you go to St bab like
all right you're not getting Jon Jones
money but you're getting you're getting
a bag now if you win you here you go TP
fight TP fight for Stipe now if I'm
Stipe I'm doing exactly what he's doing
not wait for John if I'm walking like
that no I'm I'm I'm Wai for John if I
walk like Sylvester Stallone nah we w we
waiting we waiting we waiting for that
cash
grab do you think his chances are equal
Aspen or Jones or do you prefer a
matchup for step
b um I think steep this is insane to
stay that's a great question I think St
B has a better chance and not a great
chance but has a better chance beating
Jon Jones at heavyweight since we
haven't seen Jon really at heavyweight
the one fight just start Stone booy so
and Jon still feeling himself out at
heavyweight might be a little slower we
don't know right his body looked a
little off so he's still figured himself
out Tom ason is a true heavyweight Tom
as
I think Stipe would be a bigger Underdog
to Aspen all than he would Jon Jones
tougher fight for Stipe less money
that's why he's not doing it
dumbass that's what Dana is saying to me
right now that's why he's not doing it
dumbass you see him walking the arena
with that stiff ass Rod back you know
his bad knees I get it dude I don't walk
like I used to either you know just it
it beats you up it beat you up but
outside that again you guys got to
remember Ramadan it takes a lot of these
the St the studs out of here
m ch's not fighting so forget about
that and they've announced some bigger
fights that I see porier versus our boy
saint St Denise isn't mainstream yet but
boy is he gonna
be so Dana White came back from vacation
was like cool check this out Dustin por
benois St Denise five round fight UFC
299 299 might be better than 300 right
now it's up there and now how how much
of a badass is Dustin por he go where
he's at in his career in in life you
know he's like I'm not just taking any
fights I only want bigname fights he you
know he was linked to all these other
guys bigname guys call out Nate Diaz
which I know Nate has a contract
somewhere else um so it wasn't happening
and I don't know this is just the this
why you got to love Dustin bore nobody
on this entire
roster maybe the top five guys are down
to do it outside that nobody's trying to
fight St Denise nobody Dore has nothing
more to gain there's no title on the
line there's there's nothing for him and
you're fighting this foreign French
assassin who's coming just
steamrolling our boy Matt for Rolla
Steamroller no pun
intend and there's just not a lot to
gain for for Dustin Po and he takes this
fight just
legend legend scary fight for Dustin but
we're gonna see what I like about uh
benois St Denise is he's one of these
guys where and this is what uh Anderson
Silva and big Kno coach used to always
say times are different now especially
when I was fighting he goes when you get
to the UFC there should be you should be
able to figure out a way to beat anybody
there's no warm-up fights there's no
gimmies everybody's good you should be
called with a match up and be like yep
and you know how to beat him it's not a
league where you're going to figure out
yourself it's a league where anybody can
beat anybody and you better be ready to
go there's no warm-ups in the UFC now
times are different you look at Patty
the way sugar came up things are a
little different now there's no warm-ups
anymore at this
level uh our boy Saint here did it right
when he came to the UFC he he was he had
some miles on him not older but he just
had some experience on him he's fought
tough guys before he got there Yi did
the same thing you know there's some
guys that you know come from the same
pedigree where when they get to the UFC
they're ready to go for so for Saint
it's like yeah doesn't probably make
sense makes sense guy's done it the
right way he's done it the right way
that's a good fight 299 is tasty and the
other fighting announce is going on 300
got Charles Ola versus Armen serukan
that's a fantastic
fight you got a who you got in that chin
that's a tough I think about that yeah
it is tough
call at this point maybe Armen Shin's a
bad mama jama and that's for number one
Contender remember Shin I think his
first fight and MJ's first F I think
their first fights early in their career
they fought went to decision both have
gotten so much better so don't put too
much into that but got I said it here
his here is run down like mine
man yeah that was his first fight right
fight of the night your very first fight
is against
makov in Russia fight of the night
too yeah he's goinging over that big KO
punch over
darush tough to bet against rukin right
now two two good fights they called two
good fights again 300 I'm still so
curious they got they have something up
their sleeve guarantee it I think
they're going to announce something
tomorrow cuz they said they're going to
be in the war room and Dana say is going
to announce something yeah don't call it
the war room that's what they call it
yeah I know but don't right do we have
to call it the War Room can we call it
the matchup
room let me let me bunker down the war
room we we'll report back to you easy
easier M you're doing fight matchups
let's take it easy um and the UFC needs
to come out with some big news because
they've been overshadowed because
Francis andano Dropped a Bomb well I
think
Ariel broke the news and then like
followed up like a day later like oh
guess it's out but you got Anthony
Joshua versus Francis andano hey
remember when everybody was saying he
fumbled the bag that was fun right how
many people are apologizing right
now my take on if you remember was all
good if you're leaving the
UFC the only reason it makes sense is if
you get a fury fight or if you get an
Anthony Joshua fight if you get a w if
you get those it was a smart SM move if
you don't it was the worst mistake
you've ever made in your career but not
only did he get him but I
mean almost won the damn fight most
people had him winning the fight so he
had a big time show out
now my initial thought when with Francis
an Anthony Joshua is this the cat's out
of the bag the element of surprise like
he did against Fury where Fury he did
look Fury always looks a little soft but
he and I know fur is given respected
Francis saying this be like I train just
the same I'd train if I was getting
ready for usk or Anthony Joshua I train
the exact same I trained my ass off I
don't know if that's true I I think
mentally he kind of was like this this
guy's not even box AR be able to steam
roll through him and then found out the
hard way that Francis can box his ass
off and please don't CL and he found out
he fired um he found out the hard way
that Francis is super athletic and can
box so the C out of the bag now by the
time Fury found that out he did win a
lot of later rounds right that's why
people gave him the fight you know he
got dropped on his ass and then he was
like I didn't get my [__] together here
and started performing a little better
still didn't look great but it was able
to pull it off technically uh I did
think Francis won the fight
nonetheless um that cat's out of the bad
you're not gonna you're not going to
surprise Anthony Joshua now now Anthony
Joshua has the advantage going that's
what he looks like got it I I need take
this guy serious or he will you know
beat me got it so this is a much much
tougher fight for Francis and ganana
than Tyson Fury now stylistically
Francis is an awful I'm sorry Tyson fur
is an awful matchup for anybody in the
world if if some guy is fighting Tyson
or some guy's fighting Anthony Joshua
you always have more to worry about with
Tyson Fury he's so skilled at everything
his defense his side he's a nightmare
his footwork typically he's a nightmare
for
everybody in this case with Anthony
Joshua because we're in this weird Lane
where Francis ganu showed his hand in
the fury fight and guys need to take him
serious the element surprise is gone so
now this can be a worst match up for
Francis andano can he do it absolutely
why can he do it because Anthony Joshua
gets hit Anthony Joshua doesn't have the
same footwork and elusiveness as a Tyson
Fury and when you're playing the game
with Franc and ganana who's the hardest
hitter this side of the Congo all it
takes his one freaking hit as Tyson Fury
he got dropped on his ass and that was
even a great shot Anthony Joshua's a
little more robotic and he will take
those chances and this is good if you're
a Francis fan but again cats out of the
bag it it's gonna be a much tougher
fight for Francis I'll say
that and the odds are shown that it's
going to be an easier fight for Francis
I think he's a minus or plus 700 I think
Joshua was like- 700 or something like
that which remember with Fury he was
like what was it like a plus 4,000 or
some
yeah plus 500 Underdog against Anthony
Joshua is nuts that's a win in itself
for
Francis
nuts um but again cat that the element
of surprise is is gone guys are going to
take France Francis serious now which
you know either
way Francis can lose this one and right
off in the
sunset you know I mean it's over G he
won game game set match oh but he lost
to Anthony Joshua and fury I don't give
a [__] dude got paid and technically
beat Fury if you're MMA fit do you think
win or lose obviously he's getting paid
but like is the pfl deal even relevant
like does he do we ever see him fight in
MMA and pfl I don't think so that's a
good question case you're dropping some
really good questions today and I like
this out of you new year new Casey um
the pfl thing never made sense to me and
I think that was his I think pfl is his
side chick I think it's a it's a plan B
I think with them it was like all right
hopefully because remember it's really
up in the air he was hoping it was going
to work out Fury was kind of you know
going back and forth so we didn't know
so it really dragged out but he got the
fury fight I think pfl is just the plan
b if the fury and Joshua and Wilder
stuff didn't work out it's working out
so he's like then Francis isn't that
young either that's the thing you got to
remember so it's not like he's this
young whipper snapper he's like let me
just do this and I'm gonna go you know
fight for the title of here I don't
think he cares like what's what's a pfl
belt do for francis's legacy who's he
goingon to beat name somebody that's
important how you would
beat there's no sah Gans over there
there's no Jon Jones or Aspen there's
none of that there's none of that so I
just if if you're France's manager shout
out to Markel I would look at Francis go
hey after this Joshua fight I no matter
how it goes he can Wilder's always there
W he could lose this fight to get
knocked out by Joshua and he Wilder
fights there Wilder's coming off a loss
he needs something to you know get a
spark back but um you fight Tyson Joshua
and Wilder we're going sizler we're
retiring like why at his age would you
go to the pfl and hope they can mustard
up some contenders that people are
interested in good luck dude they're
years away from that even with all the
money they have years away UFC has all
the big boys locked down contractual
wise so I just think pfl was a was the
side piece in all this equation and it
doesn't make a whole lot of sense for
him to fight Fury make all the money
Joshua make all probably more money and
then the Wilder fights there then we're
going to go do work at your age and try
to take out these guys nobody's heard of
in the pfl that nobody's watching
okay but Francis won boy did he win it's
so dope to
see but I I do think again biggest
Francis fan here thought he beat Fury
Joshua is a much more difficult fight
because the element surprise is gone and
Joshua looked fantastic in his last
fight if you're a Joshua fan I'm a huge
Joshua fan he's been up and down his the
passion hasn't really been there but
this last fight he looked
phenomenal the the the only cave out
there is Joshua does get hit more than
Fury so and he can't take it as much
either no yeah no no he do have a chin
like Fury so there there's that if they
start trading I don't care who you are
Francis lands it's unless you're
freaking Tyson Fury it's usually game
over but Joshua hits like a m trck too
for First Team all body both of them o
good Lord drip
drip what else you got Jen when is that
fight says March 8th in Saudi Arabia 10
round March 8th oh it's in Saudi Arabia
M and good for Anthony Joshua and fury
like everybody's getting paid here and
you're fighting Francis like Fran like
France is good for business you're good
for business and then if Joshua beats
Francis then you have the Tyson Fury
Anthony like hey we both beat him even
though one of you did it we both beat
them let's do our thing now everyone's
waiting for it here's the bummer that's
going be in Saudi Arabia not
London two biggest English fighters of
all time and it's not in London because
Saudi Arabia has all the money that's
sad to me that's
sad I'm with those guys though I don't
give a [__] the money yeah I know
Marquel mentioned that going to be like
Tyson not Tyson Francis is getting over
well over 10 mil I mean that's just for
like the payday but who knows
pay-per-view yeah yeah yeah yeah no he's
going Sizzler if the guarantees 10 then
pay-per-view and here's the thing I
think they're going to sell better than
the the Tyson fight because nobody in
the boxing World in some of the casuals
in MMA nobody took Francis they're like
he's get starch as stupid I'm not buying
that's waste of money now you got at
least got to give France credit like
dude can box whether you think he won or
lost the the Tyson fight I don't give a
[__] homeboy can box he's ranked top
10 I think he's number 10 either way
he's in the top 10 by wbco whatever the
hell they want to call it he the dude
can box so you're going to tune into
this and you know Joshua gets hit you
know Francis hits like M Truck had a
great performance so I think you're
going to get more of the old boxing
haters and the MMA casuals like let's
see what's happening here and this one's
going to sell more and he's going to
make more money on this then Wilder's
over there hanging out he's looking for
something to do you next daddy taking
out the big boys in boxing taking out
meaning we're all making money fighting
each other you don't have to beat them
take them
out yeah good time to be a sports fan
listen draftking sports with an official
sports betting partner of the NFL
playoffs is bring you and offer that
help make the playoffs so much better
even though they're popping this year
new customers can bet five bucks on any
game and get 200 inst in bonus bets boy
oh boy there's no team hotter right now
than the Buffalo Bills alumni what come
on I barely on the team come on dude but
Buffalo Bills have won six in a row they
won their division and they are the
hottest team in the NFL they're my pick
to go all the way if they win it I don't
know but they're definitely my pick to
go all the way bills Mafia you're on the
team you can say that hey come on again
I was barely on the team relax I didn't
even have a jersey man so anyway uh
Buffalo Bills are hot as hell right now
uh I like the ners bills Niners would be
a great game you got Miami in the dang
thing you got Dallas they could get
potentially two home games they haven't
lost in home in a hot second um Green
Bay not not terrible they're in there
I'm a Detroit fan I like the Dolphins as
well I like a lot of teams as you can
tell I like a lot of teams um not a big
Baltimore guy not a big Baltimore guy
but whatever download the draftking
Sportsbook app right now use the code
shop show new customers can bet just
five bucks to get 200 instantly in bonus
bets only on draftking Sportsbook with
codee shop show s Au
show who's reading it gambling problem
call 1800 Gambler or visit www.1 1800
gambler. net in New York call
87778 hopen or text heny
46739 in Connecticut help is available
for problem gambling call 8887895118
varies by jurisdiction void in Ontario
bonus bets expire 168 hours after
issuance see dk.com foot for eligibility
and deposit restrictions terms and
responsible gaming
resources
heyo all righty so these fights were
announced earlier but we were on I guess
holiday break Hiatus yeah so Robert
whiter versus Paul Costo paa Costa how
do you like that great fight 298 love it
that's UFC 298 yep man why would you put
that
300 um they have to have something for
us that's 298 so far dang that card is
tasty too
man yeah so could could you do Brock
Lesnar uh Derrick Lewis type of fight
you know there has to be something out
there it's so hard to figure
out
I don't know all right keep going uh on
that card as well Ian Gary versus Jeff
Neil they're supposed to do 299 but then
they got brought up a little bit earlier
for that card Bo them boys get moved
around all over y Rodriguez versus Brian
Ortega part two It's a Fight Night in
Mexico City it's a Mexican Mexican crime
yeah that's a great fight remember Brian
oras like shoulder popped out it was a
submission but his shoulder did blow out
mhm all right we kind of went over the
the fights but the b nickel one is
pretty crazy so b nickel versus Cody
Brundage the odds are insane B nickel's
A minus 1450 it's that's where B's at
you know I think every fight he's had
he's like the biggest favorite of all
time in the UFC it's just they're
bringing up
slow slower you know and that's Off to
the Races I I I would assume this the
last one the top 15
guy yeah especially if he like just
destroys him yeah yeah Cody's no punk
like he's a tough character mhm so they
destroy him yeah they also might be just
holding bo back because they're trying
to figure out the middleweight division
you know like with dupes what's Izzy
doing you had Hamot you toss Bo in there
who could probably potentially beat all
of them like we're not we got these guys
need to get bigger Stars before you toss
your crazy ass in there to beat
everybody there's that
too uh you kind of talked talked about
this already but Leon Edwards this is
from ER helani uh looks like he's going
to be at UFC 300 and potentially
fighting Bal Muhammad which I'm sure I
don't know it's not like the most
exciting fight I know but well deserved
though here here's the thing with this
is like Leon Edwards think how long it
took him to get his title shot his due
so he knows what it's like being B and
him have very similar stories right R
ripping off all these wins like where's
my title and UFC's like no you're not a
big enough name no no if I get your shot
and then you know he he's running the
table now so he knows what that's like
on the other end of of that he also
realizes why guys weren't given the
title shot if you're not a big name you
get pay-per-view points so he's like no
I need a sha cut I need this I I need to
make Bank bro so you can see both sides
of it where yes bah Muhammad deserves
the ti Shot Bar None over everybody but
if you're Leon Edwards you want as most
you're a priz fighter the point of priz
fighting is the prize to make the most
money possible balal isn't the biggest
money
maker
so you can see why Leon's like no shot's
massive like he might not be huge here
massive all over so you can make money
off sha cot there's some other guys you
can make money on so you can see why
does it but you have to fight Mohammed X
dim the rules yeah here's another quick
one Marvin vtori versus Brendan Allen I
love the ri the glow up of Brendan Allen
great name great here the glowup is
real it's a good fight yeah and Chris
Wyman's going to be back versus Bruno
Silva It's a Fight Night and I'll just
show you Chris Wyman's record as of late
how dare you man I mean just first show
back you're gonna that's a goddamn
American hero you're GNA bring up his
record you don't think we know his salty
record right now but uh yeah so Bruno
Silva his record's kind of like you know
similarish as of late so it's a good
then Brad tarz is messed up like oh your
leg fell off back from rehad here's Brad
Tavaris who's like one of the tough
toughest customers in the UFC for the
last 10 [__] years I like
this also Chris wman deserves this like
get him back man it's a good fight solid
fight not too
dangerous uh your boy Jorge mazal this
during the H holiday break as well he
just tweeted unretired I don't know if
you know any inside stuff about that
stuff but yeah I know a little something
something I know little little some some
I'm sure you guys hear some news soon
cool but not it has nothing to do with
the UFC oh okay cuz asron Ben asen's
like at UFC 300 that'd be a great
rematch nope not with UFC all
right um here's a quick one Michael
bisbing and Anthony Smith were on their
podcast believe you me and then I guess
bisbing was telling Anthony Smith he I
don't know why he took that fight you
know cuz basically it does nothing for
you which fight the last fight that you
had I'm name he lost yeah oh khil
remember when he got oh yeah Star by KH
yeah he said does nothing for him yeah
and then Anthony Smith the main thing to
take away from this is Anthony Smith
said he's not done yet he still wants to
fight yeah Fighter's gonna fight Anthony
Smith has a huge career waiting for him
too as far as commentary and being an
analyst so it's tough man because he's
going to be so far down the queue the
good news is light heavyweight you win
like three and you're a title
Contender so up there it's a little
different than lower weight classes yes
but yeah I don't I mean he's been
fighting forever he has so many fights
man yeah but I get what bising saying
like what what's what's the point man
and plus was short notice he's like you
got to have like a camp not just for
your physical part but your mental part
100% yeah bis's right MH uh we talked
about this on fight on the kid but I
don't think we talked about it here yet
so uh Conor McGregor calling out or not
calling out saying that he has a match
up with Michael Chandler at
International fight week I think it's a
little I I get for for Chandler it's
like
like he'll do like even if he was like
this fights
at 145 or even 265 CH like yeah yeah he
just seems like desper like he needs
this big money fight right he he'll do
whatever it takes you know it's like the
guy who's chasing the hot chick so I get
it he'll do whatever and compromise
whatever just to get this fight to get
the payday um I have a a buddy who's
close he's in Connor's camp and he told
me Connor's over 200 lbs right right now
he kind of looks it though yeah
uhhuh so he's not positive if he's over
200 but he's definitely not under 20000
like right around 200 maybe 202 201 but
he's two hundo so Conor just doesn't he
doesn't want to cut like he's like I'm
fighting but I'm not cut kill my bike
cut I like he likes being you know likes
to feel strong and so yeah that's why
this happening do you think Chandler
does worse at
185 I you this fight had by no chance
goes the full five rounds or three
rounds what the hell they decide to do
um they're both going to hit much harder
having you know more weight their chins
are going to be a little better um but
this somebody's getting knocked out them
being this heavy this strong 85 they're
both going to be a lot slower but
they're going to punch harder so no
chances and their cardio is going to be
worse so no chance these two let
especially the Way Chandler fights
regardless of what weight there's no way
this goes the distance distance and
you've been around both guys is Chandler
that much smaller than Conor just his
frame like his height no I Chandler's
thicker okay Chandler's thick boy thick
legs like he's a thicker human being
like think about Conor used to fight at
45 Chandler could never I mean that
that's not happening his legs are 45
Chandler's thick dude yeah he might be
shorter but he's a lot stalker and thick
explosive
too all right another quick
break all right let's take a little
break here let me ask you Gearheads how
long has you're probably not Gearhead if
you haven't changed your spark plugs but
how long has it been since you changed
your freaking spark plugs replacing your
spark plugs can restore efficiency and
performance to your vehicle whatever it
is better spark plugs bigger spark plugs
the spacing figure it out right now at
O'Reilly Auto Parts where I get a bunch
of my stuff from get a $12 O'Reilly gift
card after rebate when you purchase four
or more select AC Delco spark plug
maintain your performance and fuel
mileage with new spark plugs from
O'Reilly Auto Parts you can also improve
visibility with new wiper blades right
now I just replaced mine on the
lightning because they're 20 years old
uh right now save 12 bucks on a pair of
rainx rugged XL wiper blades plus get
two times o Reward Points an extra large
profile premium feature makes rugged XL
blades the right choice for extreme
weather driving durability the
professional Parts people will even
install your new wiper blade for free
from spark plugs to wiper blades and
more save now with do it right deals in
store at or rilly Auto Parts at O'Reilly
auto.com o
O'Reilly Auto Parts nice ow man
that all right
Progressive boy we're just loow up here
this episode of the shop show with the
new set is brought to you by Progressive
Insurance most of you listening right
now are probably multitasking yep while
you're listening to this all right
hopefully you're not driving but
cleaning exercising maybe even grocery
shopping but if you're not in some kind
of moving vehicle there's something else
you can be doing right now getting an
auto quote from Progressive Insurance
it's easy and you could save money by
doing it right from your phone driver
who save by switching to Progressive
save nearly $750 on average and autoc
customers qualify for an average of
seven discounts discounts for having
multiple vehicles on your policy being a
homeowner and so so much more so just
like your favorite podcast Progressive
will be with you 247 365 days a year so
you're protected no matter what
multitasking right now quote your car
insurance at progressive.com to join the
over 28 million drivers who trust
Progressive uh national average 12-
month savings of
$744 by new customer surveyed who Sav
the with Progressive between June 2022
and may 2023 potential savings will vary
discount no avilable in all states and
situations Progressive Auto Insurance
Shopify oh you didn't want to split them
up huh that's we have we'll split up
again another one
last um listen when I started this
podcast an online store
was Furthest Thing from my mind I was
shipping firing the kid merch me and my
brother doing out of our buddy's house
it was exhausting uh but I wish I use
Shopify cuz so easy and we use Shopify
now all right name all right shopy is
the global Commerce platform that helps
you sell at every stage of your business
from the launcher online shop stage to
the first real life store stage all the
way to do we just hit a millon order
stage Shopify is there to help you grow
with your auction off autograph apparel
Sleek skis whatever it is Shopify helps
you sell everywhere from their
all-in-one e-commerce platform to their
in-person POS system whatever whatever
you're selling shopify's got you covered
Shopify helps you turn brow browsers
into buyers with the internet's best
converting checkout up to 36% better
compared to the other leading Commerce
platforms sell more with less effort
thank to
Shopify last one Happ people no that no
bud sorry we we finish Shopify go down
my bad cuz you got to do uh the oh my
bad my bad you drinking this morning
again no all right all right here we go
2024 all right uh because business that
grow grow with Shopify sign up for $1
per month trial period at shopify.com /
Shob all lowercase that's SE go to
shopify.com Shob to right now to grow
your business no matter what stage
you're in shopify.com Shob CH Ching okay
last one how you gon to move on without
that code dog I've been do this too
long uh this episode the shop show is
also brought to you by happy hippo it's
2024 if you've been waiting all last
year like I don't know if I want try
Crum I don't know well guess what now
you can trust the best katum on the
planet the only source that I trust it
is the absolute best crat on the planet
and however you want to use it if you
don't like powders all good but they
have powders they have gummies they have
cadps they have the freaking Crum
concentrated shots this is butterscotch
they got it all the powder like I said
they got the energy shots they got laffy
they got gummies anything that you can
think of and you want to try create them
get that mine right it's my Limitless p
i do it on every pod that I do it's
happy hippo.com go to happy hippo.com
promo code is thick 23 for 20% off and
for 2024 you get 20% off for the rest of
your life share with a friend use them
many times you want try create them
gives you that nice good feeling with
I'm working out doing a pod just
chitchatting with other dads your boys
on crom and it's from Happy Hippo happy
hippo.com prco
th23 all righty I don't know if you want
to talk about this but Manny Pacquiao
was at ryzen event and he said that he
will be boxing Floyd Mayweather again
REM match that's
sad okay who's gonna watch that dude
people were upset when they were even
out of their Prime and fought and cost
us a 100 bucks and and Manny Pacquiao
didn't disclose he had one arm so now
they're going to fight when they're both
their nuts or gray on the ground come on
dog who's gonna pay like who wants to
see that what demand is there I don't
get
it but get yours and this is also a
little bit older but number Ian Mado had
Jeff Neil's face on a shirt yeah and
then now Kevin Holland wore this shirt
with Ian Gary He's boys with Jeff
Neil but
yeah and then these are kind of weird
but I'll just play for you so this is
Johnny Walker apparently his brother is
going to be in UFC heavyweight division
they're both jacked and they look very
different too right well one's
white and then they just wait that's his
brother there he looks different there I
know they're both bodied up
and that's some other guy but that's the
liver King on the left that's the
Brazilian liver King why they pumping
their wieners in the air like that all
that's what I
was there's music get your assai tail
out of our face there dog why is he in
that little sunga like that his
brother's at heavyweight huh yeah 26
years old damn he's big 11 and0 and this
is from Crash anime and also they posted
this I have no idea what this is but
I'll just play for it this is Charles
Oliva
I think it's cold water they're washing
his
feet he looks like Anthony Pettis there
yeah a little
bit wait are people saying this is like
gay because brazilian's in a cold
shower it's just very weird look at him
his boy just showering in the cold there
can't shower with the bros anymore that
close though that close in Brazil I but
CH they're in a third world country dude
everyone's like how they not each have
their own I [__] they're in the middle
of the flla that's the only water they
can clean while they can get man even if
you don't have I mean fair play to you
shower with the Bros go ahead make fun
of me yeah shower with the Bros and this
cold water and bundle up or don't shower
at all I'm going to shower with the Bros
give my back dog don't be gay have you
guys ever showered with your Bros
I mean you played sport man yeah I mean
yeah I mean I want have my wiener out
they're also in their trunks dude people
are homophobic I I don't have I don't
get why this is a video like I don't I
don't think it looks gay it's like yeah
him his boys are showering after then
the FLL whatever we're need you to hit
the showers chin maybe one day together
team thick boy showering here man I
don't give a [__] you guys are weird man
all right I think this is the last one
so Sean Strickland was with with that
girl Nina Marie and I can't play the
video cuz I guess the video video got
censored on YouTube on her Channel but
it's basically him doing like those
Roman candles shooting at people's faces
and bodies he had a shirt off too and he
got hit in the face this is before his
fight with dupes too he got hit in the
face yeah he n hit him in the face
someone with a Roman Candle if you see
the video is he okay I mean I'm sure
sure he's okay we can't play this but
I'll play it for
you he see got shot in the face there
but that's how crazy it
is one if UFC's like hey Nina can you
not shoot our champion in the face with
a Roman Candle she probably didn't mean
to but also this some wild
[__] oh hell no that ain't for me Chim
would you rather be shot with fireworks
or jump in that cold shower with a bunch
of dudes like Charles Olivera in the
face though who
knows I'd rather be in that shower with
Bros all day I'll risk it with the
fireworks oh wow you're that being that
close to the dudes and they're like
rubbing each other there's no weer and
butt stuff going on man all right dude
you know open your mind Shen open your
mind anyhoo that's pretty much it other
than the fight this weekend yeah you got
your first card of the Year UFC Fight
Night uh main event's good Russ card's
pretty tasty for a fight night I'll take
it where's that Apex M 4:00 PS J Miller
doing the damn thing it'd be dope if Jim
Miller wins this put him on 300 Rick
Simone Mario Batista that's a great one
Andre ly holy
schnikes
prelim
wow Matthew uh simburger simburger best
here in the game he's always fun too fun
fun uh yeah decent fight night yeah I'll
take it that that that that made event
if there's like a draw or an eye poke
people are going to freak out it's not
good but we'll see what happens there
but enjoy the fights kid welcome to 2024
this is the first show of
2024 uh housekeeping notes I am in
Nashville uh the keep on trucking tour
kicks off January 25th in Nashville one
night only at zany in Nashville I go
straight from there uh January 26 27th
Friday and Saturday in Austin Texas at
the Vulcan gas company I'm in Austin
Texas so get your te tickets for an Asal
on the 25th Austin on 26 27th tick a
thick boy.com all right kids that's it
love you like subscribe 2024 is here New
Year same me uh let's have a good year
kids all right love you thanks for
watching thanks for the support I'm
out